Duane Lee Chapman, better known as "Dog the
Bounty Hunter," made a name for himself by
bringing criminals to justice while urging
them to change their ways.
The tanned and mullet-topped reality television
star nabbed fugitives and scored major ratings
for over a decade before pretty much disappearing
from the airwaves.
But Dog hasn't been locked in a kennel.
This legend of liberty has remained active
across the American frontier.
Here's what he's been up to for the last few
years...
Uncaged Cage
According to ABC News, New Orleans police
arrested actor Nicolas Cage in 2011, after
a domestic dispute with his wife Alice Kim
got a little out of hand.
Dog, a fan of Cage's, later bailed him out
of jail.
Charges against Cage were dropped later that
year, and we're still waiting for someone
to make a TV series out of this burgeoning
friendship.
Arrest warrant for Beth
In 2013, Dog and his wife Beth Chapman's vacation
in Colorado was interrupted by a loud car.
According to TMZ, Beth shouted insults at
one of the passengers, before calling the
police and leaving before officers arrived.
The teenagers suffered no consequences...but
calling a person names is actually a crime
in Colorado.
One passenger filed a harassment complaint
against Beth.
When she didn't pick up the summons, police
issued a warrant for her arrest.
She later turned herself in, saving Dog from
the awkward task of bringing his own wife
to justice.
Dog talked about his time in prison
In 2015, Dog revealed that in 1976, he was
charged and convicted of the murder of an
alleged pimp and drug dealer.
Though Dog's friend pulled the trigger while
he was waiting in the car, Chapman received
a five-year prison sentence, ultimately serving
18 months.
Years later, Chapman dealt with the incident
during an episode of Dog and Beth: On the
Hunt's third season to show people it's possible
to turn your life around.
Step-daughter arrested for bank robbery
According to Hawaii News Now, Dog's step-daughter
Nicole Gillespie allegedly robbed the downtown
Honolulu Territorial Savings Bank, in 2015.
Upon learning of her arrest, Dog issued a
statement, revealing that Nicole had been
estranged from the rest of the family for
some time:
"It's always difficult and disheartening when
someone you knew as a child grows up and chooses
a life of crime [...] We have not seen "Nickie"
in over 10 years.
Watching her on Crimestoppers left us all
shocked and heart broken."
Ended his show to save bounty hunting
Chapman ended his three-season follow-up show
for CMT, Dog and Beth: On the Hunt, in 2015,
saying he wanted to combat bail reform efforts
across America.
Calls for reform started after a rash of unfortunate
incidents, like a man being shot to death
by bounty hunters in Idaho.
According to In Touch, Dog felt his energy
was better spent working to stop proposed
laws that included establishing requirements
such as minimum-age limits for bounty hunters
and licenses to carry concealed weapons.
And things are going Dog's way.
In 2016, according to the Idaho Press-Tribune,
his efforts helped defeat such a bill in Idaho,
almost one year after the death of the aforementioned
man.
He opposes Stand-Your-Ground laws
During an interview with HuffPost Live, Dog
voiced his opinions on the sensitive topic
of gun control.
First, he sought to debunk the gun lobby's
argument that "the only thing that can stop
a bad guy with a gun is a good guy with a
gun."
He insisted he's never used a gun on any of
the criminals he's caught—just tasers and
pepper spray.
He also argued that so-called "stand your
ground" laws are "bullcrap."
Not the opinions you'd expect to hear out
of a guy who looks like Chapman, or one in
his line of work.
Just goes to show you can't judge a book by
its cover...or a bounty hunter by his mullet.
Cultural impact
If you've watched this video to this point,
it's because you know all about our friend
Dog, and recognize him as more than just a
bounty hunter with beautiful hair.
That's because in the years since he first
took to television, he's become more than
just a strong man bringing people to justice...he's
become a cultural icon.
A real-life Boba Fett, he's been referenced
in shows like American Dad!, Family Guy, and
South Park.
And when a show as huge as The Simpsons makes
reference to you, you know your legacy is
secure.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to see more
videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know if you
want to see Dog back on TV...